hello my name is Brett champion and
today I'll be talking about what's new
and visualization and the Wolfram
language including uncertainty
visualizations and multi panel outputs
and other improvements over the past
version Ursa
good morning my name is Brett champion
I'm the manager of the visualization
team here at Wolfram and today I'm going
to be talking about what's new in terms
of visual visualization functionality in
the system before I get into my content
I'm going to advertise the talks of
several of the other members on my team
so later this afternoon
Emmanuel Garces is going to be speaking
about geovisualization what's new or
what's forthcoming in 12 what's new in
some of the recent versions tomorrow at
12:30 Nirmal mala pakka is going to be
discussing complex valued visualization
which is in pretty much an entirely new
set of functions coming in version 12
and then tomorrow afternoon at 2:30 min
is going to be discussing recent
advances in labeling and automated
labeling in the Wolfram language
individual in the visualization
functions my talk is everything else so
let's see jumping right in a lot of what
we do is iterative and so we introduced
an option and then it rolls out over a
sequence of versions to the hundred plus
visualization functions where it may
make sense one of those is scaling
functions in 11.3 we added support for
scaling functions and list point plot 3d
I'm not going to show an example of that
coming in 12 we're adding it to the
discrete plots partially to support the
documentation effort of some of those
some work that the symbolic steams have
been working on and so here we have
discrete plot of sterling s1 which grew
just incredibly quickly I mean actually
this is absolute value of sterling s1
because it alternates in sign and I just
wanted to show the growth in magnitude
and and so now with the scaling
functions you know we can do this on a
log scale and you can see on the log
scale yo it goes from 1 up to 10 to the
50th by the time you're at one of the
parameters equals 50 just insane growth
on this thing I also have it for 3d so
here's Stirling s1 again plotted over
both of its parameters and again you can
see along that space it's going up to
the 10 to the 52 number the 60 very
quickly so the next feature I want to
talk about is some improvements we've
made to plot markers and to mesh
especially with regard to like plot and
list plot and a lot of the curve
generators so this is actually a version
6 was not version 6 version 11.3 results
if you change the curve colors it's a
version 6 result where the mesh always
used the same color no matter how many
curves you have and so I have 4 curves
and they're red blue green and yellow
but all the all the mesh points are blue
so coming in 12 the mesh points will
follow the plot style by default which
should make a bunch of people happy I
know that this came up frequently on
Stack Exchange and community and this
sort of thing we also fixed some bugs
along the way that
had dozens of reporters but I don't I'm
not showing an example of those because
I'm not gonna show off bugs we also in
the process of overhauling that aspect
of plot markers have updated the plot
markers in general so there's a little
bit more flexibility in terms of how to
specify what the shapes are how to
specify what the size of the shapes are
and if I look at you know the automatic
markers then if I select one of these if
I select it well then this is actually
now a graphical element rather than
being a string you know a character in a
string which should give us better
politely better positioning slightly
better sizing shouldn't make the
graphics too much bigger and I'm looking
forward to better positioning let's see
still on the topic of markers so in
version 11 point 3 I believe we added
vector markers as an option to vector
plot and stream markers as an option to
stream plot endless stream plot in this
vector plot and all their other cousins
so so by default you do a vector plot
and you get a bunch of fairly generic
looking arrows and vector markers and
stream markers allows you to control you
know I think a very nice way what
those arrows look like I mean what the
shape of the arrows are and how they're
positioned so we have a lot of named
[Music]
marker shapes and so we have dart being
used on this vector plot and it's sort
of a
anncr arrow dart actually goes back dart
and drop which is being used for the
stream plot actually both go back to
version 7 but it was this weird syntax
using vector style goes to this string
and if you wanted that shape and it to
be read then there was further magic
incantations that I always had to go
back and check emails to see what they
were so we factored the shape out and
made sure that it combines well with
vector style and plot style and and
these sorts of things so that it's easy
to document easy to predict what you're
going to get this is probably isn't
going to show up well on the screen but
these have Auto completions and similar
to plot themes the auto completions have
little iconic versions of what they look
like so you don't have to say well what
is pointer again
you can look and see that pointer is an
arrowy
you know a triangle sort of thing and so
thank you to the front-end team for
allowing us to do that in the auto
completions let's go back to dirt and so
the other thing I mentioned is that we
have control over what the arrows look
like and in the case of vectors of the
vector plots we have control over how
their placed and we're using placed for
this and so we have at the moment three
named positions for technical reasons
it's not arbitrary as although I don't
know that arbitrary is necessarily that
useful although I'm sure there are cases
for it but the most important ones are
being able to say that my arrow is going
to start at the point
arrow is going to end at the point or
though defaults is that the arrow is
centered on the point and these three
plots show you why having them centered
is our default setting even though
everybody sort of naively expects it to
be this case that I have arrows coming
out of my points and and in fact we
Center the arrow on the point and and
the reason is is that if you look at
this one where you have sort of this
circular field it's all sort of tilted
it feels tilted a little bit and then
the other and the one on the far right
is sort of tilted the other way and so
by centering the vector you sort of
cancel out you know these visual effects
and visual biases so now into so the
really cool new stuff so we are
supporting natively within the
visualization functions at least some of
the visualization functions support for
uncertainty using around which as they
are you giving you talk about around
nope okay so you get to come to me
so around is basically what we came up
with when we reluctantly decided that we
couldn't use plus minus and so we have a
value and then we have some uncertainty
associated with that value and I'll just
copy one of those outs that was weird
okay if we look it around its type sets
as a plus/minus
sort of looking thing and and so we're
supporting around in list plots dateless
plot bar charts a lot of the close
cousins of those so list log plot and
date list log plot and that sort of
thing in future versions we'll roll it
out to more and more the visualization
functions so plot and probably the 3d
things and anywhere that it sort of
makes sense
amusingly things like pie charts support
around they don't do anything with it
they just look at the first argument the
main value at least for now at some
point maybe there will be some weird
representation of uncertainty in pie
charts but I've yet to see an instance
of those that looks good and can be
easily interpreted but anyway so so the
left plot we have just a bunch of
y-values and uncertainty associated with
them in the right plac we have
uncertainty associated with the x and
the y values and so we get the error
bars in both directions
we aren't limiting ourselves to around
we're taking the opportunity to also
support uncertainty using interval and
all these functions the visual how it
looks visually is a little bit different
so interval is just a line showing the
extent where as with around we have the
caps at the top and the bottom and so we
have controls for that so we have two
new options interval markers and
interfer interval markers style so we
can say that we want bands or we want
the bars or
whatever representation sort of makes
the most sense for your data in your
application and then the interval
interval markers style I don't know that
I've had to say that a lot out loud
allows us to control the normal
parameters of how the markers are drawn
so thickness and color and if I wanted
to make them dotted for some reason I
could by default they're gonna inherit
from the plot style but you have sort of
full control and probably even more
control in future versions so here's an
example using actual data that Jeff
Bryant's put into alpha for us so that
we could query for it I'm not actually
showing the query it's all hidden in
this I can eyes output but it's is
giving us the and I forgot to change the
text size for the labels so we have a
bunch of it I mean these are all
identified exoplanets and the horizontal
axis is the estimated mass of the planet
and the vertical axis is the radius and
meters and so this is a log linear or
list log linear plot so we have a log
scale along on the x axis and a linear
scale on the y axis and then we're
styling the points and styling the
uncertainties and some of those
uncertainties are quite large and this
is the nice set of planets yes
because I'm in you Lee scaled the tick
marks I changed the stuff I edited the
stylesheet to have right there's nothing
in the syntax although you may have
noticed although a lot of times it's
really small that's I'm alighting a lot
of options and so right so like up here
there are options hidden behind this dot
dot dot that aren't you know immediately
relevant to I mean in this case it's
making the lines thicker so that they
show up better for the people standing
at the back of the room
but I forgot to change the style for the
frame labels so the final thing that
we're working on is my attempt to break
graphics grid and by break I mean
hopefully improve it in ways that
outweigh any damage that I do otherwise
and so here I have four random walks I
have so walk is just a function that is
doing a list line plot of accumulated
blah blah blah
and so in this case what happens is you
know sort of everything looks not well
wind up and and so we have let's get
that gray one so sort of each of those
you know outer graphics is lined up but
within that I mean there's a lot of
wasted space say at the top here and
whatnot and so with the new changes to
graphics grid we're adjusting the
graphics which graphics grid does anyway
in ways that allow us to line up frame
edges in ways so that yeah
that's a straight you know those are
honest on the same line those are on the
same line so on and then horizontally as
well and at the moment it's mainly in
this case changes to the aspect ratio
and some of the padding outside of the
frame so the padding that the labels are
going in the frame labels and frame
ticks are going into so the other part
is sort of a more general approach on
this which is also going to roll out
slowly starting in version 12 which is
the ability for the visualization
function is to create gridded output
natively so here are a slightly
different set of random walks and I'm
just I've thrown them in list line plots
and by default list line plot says you
have four data sets I'm going to give
each of them a unique color and they're
all going to be smashed on top of each
other so what we're doing is we're going
to reuse the plot layout option to the
visualization functions in a way that we
say you can use more than one plot and
so in this case we have column and
everything is on the same column and
because we know that all of these are
coming from I mean we know information
about where these graphics are coming
from we're able to make assumptions and
optimize for it to some extent and so
what happens is you'll notice that we've
cut out a lot of the labels you know so
obviously the top three plots
don't have their labels going across the
bottom and if I do you know a gridded
output then we get the same thing in the
other direction so we're only labeling
sort of the outermost set of scales now
I'm really wondering what's going on
with that bottom left plot because that
looks like a bug because the other thing
that we're doing is we're even adjusting
what labels are oh I know that's okay it
is a book but not the one I thought
easier to see is that what can happen is
if we had the same labels on every axis
and we duplicated them repeatedly then
what would happen is that potentially so
this minus 150 here at the bottom end of
the plot range because all of these have
the same vertical plot range it actually
sticks down a little bit and so if it
was here it would stick down a little
bit it would get really close to this 50
and we don't want them to be too close
to each other and so we don't draw it
here the plan is that will actually put
a tick where it would be but it won't
have its label and similarly here and
then the top one will probably get it
back again but we might need to remove
the 50s
and so there's a little bit of
adjustment and still figuring out what
looks good and what tricks work and
which ones don't
entirely so continual refinement but yes
so we'll be using plot Leon to generate
these nicely aligned graphics outputs
and at least in version 12 any options
that you set for this plot are going to
apply to all of them so if I come over
here and say plot style goes to red then
[Music]
they're all going to be red and if you
say red blue purple orange then they're
all going to be orange because that's
what plot style does with a list if you
only have one curve in the data set
which is essentially what's happening
under hand under the hood is that it's
calling list line plot of this data set
with its options this data set with its
options etc etc at some point in the
future we will probably have a way to
address styles and options toward
individual plots but not yet and and so
that concludes my talk and we have a few
minutes left if people have questions or
I'll be probably out in the hallway
immediately following this talk if you
have additional questions or things that
you want to ask but and I'll take one
last moment to plug Emmanuel and men and
nirmal's talks at 3:30 today and 12:30
tomorrow and 2:30 tomorrow yes Jeff
host v12 so Jeff is asking about having
one plot or one frame with two or more
vertical axes and there are plans for it
a lot of the work that's going on for
this I expect to be relevant for that
there's some parts that will be
completely fresh for that and it's not
for twelve but hopefully a version soon
after that yep okay thank you
[Applause]